donald trump once again casting down on
his trade deal with china
saying tuesday that he chose to cancel
last saturday's planned meeting
between both sides an advisor had said
that the phase one trade deal
struck in january was on track but
beijing is falling behind on its
purchases of u.s goods outlined in that
plan
and tensions are growing elsewhere
washington has singled out chinese firms
doing business in the u.s in recent
weeks
including tick tock owner bite dance and
wechat
and for more on this i'm joined by my
colleague chelsea delaney chelsea good
to have you with us
chelsea are there signs that the trade
agreement is falling through and what
would that mean
well as with anything relating to the
u.s administration there's a certain
amount of rhetoric and there's there's a
lot of different voices coming from the
white house so
other people within the administration
have said the deal is on track trump has
been
a little more cagey on that he did say
yesterday that he doesn't want to talk
to china right now and that
we'll have to see what happens with with
this trade deal so
he is sort of walking it back a little
bit and there is there is technical
reason for that china has really fallen
behind on its on the commitments that
made in january
to to buy an additional 200 billion
dollars worth of u.s goods
over the next two years it's only bought
about uh five percent of the energy
uh products that it said it would buy
it's really behind on agricultural
products as well
and that's really because of the
pandemic they really can't be
importing as much as they had planned to
so there is a reason for that but
for the u.s it's another sort of stick
to be china with right now
does either side in this case benefit
from the trade agreement falling through
probably not uh if we were go back to
the end of last year
the trade war was really damaging for
the global economy for companies on
both sides so for for china for the u.s
it would be really
uh not great economically if they do
have to go back to a situation where
they're raising tariffs where companies
are getting hit really hard
on on these on these economic issues as
well
all right chelsea delaney with dw
business thank you for your analysis